O que que tu faz agora, Alan? Agora eu
crio workflows [música] dentro do LX que
vão percorrer todos os caminhos que eu
preciso para executar alguma coisa. Ó,
mas como é que tá fazendo a IA? Fica
trabalhando durante 1 hora, 2 horas, 3
horas, 4 horas, foram mais de 12 horas,
se não me engano, 13 horas trabalhando
seguidas, né? Dou um comando e ela vai
ficar trabalhando 13 horas seguidas.
Às vezes a gente tá tão avançado
estudando, né, workflows, múltiplos
agentes e um monte de coisa que quando a
gente não para para pensar que a verdade
é que o mercado todo está lá para trás,
o mercado todo, gente, não sabe nem o
que é a gente. O mercado não sabe nem de
A maioria das pessoas não sabem o que é
o workflow, a maioria das pessoas não
sabe que existe esse negócio de Iox,
cloud code. A gente fica pensando, né?
Nossa, deve todo mundo tá fazendo todo,
deve todo mundo deve estar com o
computador aberto, criando um monte de
coisa. Ah, todo mundo tá criando um app.
Não, não tá. O prompt, a, a
prompt tá aqui, ó. É só digitar. Quero
qualquer digita qualquer coisa nesse
nesse aqui, ó, nesse chatt que ele vai
criar o prompt para ti, tá?
Ah,
porque eu nem consigo colar aqui, né?
No, eu tentei colar aqui o prompt
inteiro desse de pesquisa para vocês
aqui, mas ele dá que é 1000. Ele ele só
esse prompt tá com 4.000 caracteres. E
aqui eu tenho limite de 1000 caracteres
para enviar aqui para vocês. Mas é só
digitar.
Eu o que eu digitei aqui foi isso aqui,
ó. Vou mandar para vocês.
Foi isso que eu botei. Que que eu
mandei? Eu mandei isso aqui e joguei
dentro aqui do novo chat. Foi isso que
eu fiz. Só isso. Esse aqui é para
pesquisa, tá? É para pesquisa.
novamente. Ah, aula vai ser sobre esse
cara. Não, eu tô mostrando como a gente
fazia antigamente,
ó. Então, aqui ele me trouxe, né,
relatórios, blá blá. Esse aqui já me
trouxe outras informações.
Tá continuando aqui. Esse aqui também o
Grock é muito bom. Por quê? Porque o
Grock traz informações em tempo real da
internet, né, do que as pessoas estão
conversando, etc. Tá?
Ah, como acessar o pesquisa rendar? Ele
ele tá lá no no chat de PT, você
consegue, eu mandei o link, acabei de
mandar o link aqui também e digitar lá
pesquisa lendária, vai encontrar, tá
bom? Beleza, Alan. Isso aqui é da época
da pré-história que tu usava esse cara
aqui. Quanto tempo faz tu não usa? Sei
lá, uns ano, dois anos que eu não uso
esse cara aqui. O que que tu faz agora,
Alan? Agora eu crio workflows
dentro do LX que vão percorrer todo os
caminhos que eu preciso para executar
alguma coisa.
Então, mostrei para vocês aqui
a parte de como eu fazia. Agora eu quero
mostrar como eu faço. Posso?
Daí eu vou falar sobre o que acabou de
acontecer, tá bom?
Então vou mostrar agora o que que eu,
como é que eu faço isso. Vou dar, vou
fazer o seguinte, eu vou pedir a mesma
coisa para ele. Lembra que que eu pedi
aqui atrás, ó? Deixa eu pegar ali o que
eu tinha pedido. Foi aqui o que eu eu
digitei aqui.
Deixa eu pegar aqui,
ó. Isso aqui.
Vou pedir isso aqui para ele. Tá?
Agora eu vou mostrar
como funciona dentro do meu sistema isso
aqui, né? Isso aqui é forma arcaica.
Dentro do meu sistema
eu uso o cloud code. Então, deixa eu
abrir aqui a telinha do cloud code.
Aqui dentro eu uso ox.
Ah, eu vou ter que usar cloud code.
Não dá fazer no codex, dá fazer no
grabit. Pode fazer onde quiser.
Dei bastante zoom aqui para vocês verem.
Escrevo o cloud. Aqui eu tenho um que se
chama tech research. Eu tenho vários
aqui. Ah, eu tenho um que se chama tech
research. É esse cara aqui. Que que eu
vou fazer? Eu vou botar aqui só colar a
minha pergunta e vou dar um enter.
Deu.
Esse é o comando. E agora o que que ele
vai fazer? Aa agora ele vai fazer todo
aquele processo lá gigantesco, né? Que
tem várias etapas, vários processos.
Ele vai fazer esse cara aqui, ele vai a
pergunta puramente pesquisa de mercado
uma implementação e segue dentro do
escopo. Tem uma oportunidade de gerado
brasileiro. Vez vou seguir o fluxo fase
zero. Lá carregou guard rails com
pipeline tem 13 fases com múltiplas 13
fases com múltiplas chamadas. Eu vou
criar um tesk de tracking, depois rodar
fase zero e 1.5 deopos em paralelo
conceitualmente.
Alan, isso tem no free? Não, isso aqui
tá no Enterprise que custa R$ 48.000
hoje.
Ah, não tá no free, né? Como vocês
viram, é toda a metodologia que eu tenho
que gigantesca, etc., né? né? Isso aqui
é muito tempo meu.
E que que eu fiz, inclusive criar aqui
para vocês verem
e para vocês verem até, né, que assim
existe valor nesse mercado. É quando
falo R$ 48.000 para que é uma das
funções que tem dentro dele, eu resolvi
criar isso aqui, ó. Ah, não, ele
funciona, funciona em qualquer lugar,
né? Codex, por aí vai. Eu criei um
painel onde aqui tá todas minhas
pesquisas que eu faço com essa que vocês
estão vendo, onde eu consigo ver até um
modelo de relatórios, ó. Então eu posso
vir aqui ver um contra o outro,
posso ver aqui, né? Eu posso alterar
aqui os pesos e descobrir, por exemplo,
com base naquilo que eu quero, qual que
vale mais a pena? Por exemplo, qual que
é mais barato e tem um e cria designs
melhores, qual que tem um suporte
melhor? Qual que tem um maior market
fit?
R$
48.000 é para ter acesso ao iOS
Enterprise, que é todo o meu negócio.
Não, eu não vou vender ierprise hoje
aqui, mas eu quero entregar para algumas
pessoas algumas coisas de graça total
para vocês ficarem aqui até o final da
live que eu vou mostrar e outras para
quem quiser entrar na turma do LX
Fundamentals.
Mas o o Enterprise ele nem tá à venda.
Esse aqui foi o valor da primeira turma.
Deixa eu ver se o pessoal já atualizou
aqui o valor. Essa aqui é a parte da
primeira turma. A gente já preencheu as
vagas. Isso para fazer parte do
Exterprise, só tendo feito se formando
no Advanced, né? Então é uma coisa que
nem tá vendo assim, ah, não quero entrar
nisso aí, nem tá à venda, tá?
Ó, 48.000 aqui. Daí tem várias coisas
aqui. Não tem porque eu falar sobre Ax
Enterprise, é só para quem se formou no
Advanced, né?
Ah, mas deixa eu voltar aqui.
Ele vai fazer agora o processo inteiro
de pesquisa, tá? Processo inteiro. Estão
vendo aqui que ele vai fazer 1 milhão de
coisas. Eu quero mostrar para vocês. Ah,
mas como é que tá fazendo a IA? Fica
trabalhando durante 1 hora, 2 horas, 3
horas, 4 horas. Eu cheguei já a deixar
ela trabalhando. Foram mais de 12 horas,
se não me engano, 13 horas trabalhando
seguidas, né? Dou um comando e ela vai
ficar trabalhando 13 horas seguidas.
Porque eu já validei vários processos
manualmente por bastante tempo.
Esse foi um deles, né? Daquilo que vocês
viram ali. Eu tenho um monte de um monte
de documento no meu notion, um monte de
processos que eu fiz. O que acontece
quando a gente tem isso? A gente é capaz
de criar workflows.
Alon, o que que são workflows?
Workflows para quem já, quem é que já
mexeu com o N8N da vida ou alguma coisa
nesse sentido.
E aqui que já mexeu, pessoal, 8N com
funil de e-mail.
Ó, tem uma galera aqui que já mexeu.
Quando você trabalha, você faz alguns
workflows, né? O que que é um workflow,
Alon? Work é trabalho, flow, né? é
fluxo. Então é um fluxo de trabalho.
E o que que inclusive eu tava lá no
lançamento da Versel lá no São Francisco
há umas três quinta-feiras atrás, onde
eles lançaram o sistema de workflow da
Versel para ficar funcionando online. E
workflows
depois, né, dessa época a gente passou
por uma fase falando sobre chat GPT.
Isso foi lá em 2023. Em 2024 a gente
começou a falar muito sobre eh começar a
falar sobre agentes. Em 2025 começou a
se falar bastante sobre agentes, né? Em
2026 quem tá por dentro das coisas
nem fala mais em prompt, não fala mais
em em agente. [música] Ah, porque tudo
isso tá dentro de workflows, tá dentro
de [música] processos mapeados.